regarde lien tous ces animaux fabuleux
était consciente de la chance que tu as
de vivre ici mais je veux pas vivre ici
on n'est là que depuis un mois elle a
besoin d'un peu de temps
un lion blanc est né dans votre ferme si
tu savais comme je m'en tape de ton
pauvre lionceaux j'ai pas poindre un ami
roman installé
ça clashe ans et ados
g
mieux faire c'est chez toi
elle est enfin heureuse dont il ya ça
reste un animal sauvage et maintenant il
ne quitte plus son enclos suite
j'en reviens pas que tes risques il est
vite ton frère tu dois partir je
prétends que trop tard c'est terminé il
sera vendu aux premiers acheteurs qui se
présente pas il est emmené à la réserve
est en gros et y travaille mais a
disparu
je te jure je vais la retrouver
charlie est mon meilleur ami
je pouvais pas la brigade
j'ai fait mon jardin
[Musique]